[Musique]
bonjour pour commencer je citerai
abraham lincoln qui disait aucun homme
n'est assez de mémoire pour réussir dans
le mensonge
lisez pas que des conneries mon frère
jumeau être invités du jour et franck
c'est l'homme le plus mythomane du monde
bonjour franck bonjour vous avez
exactement la même voie que granby nord
grâce mineur parce qu'en fait à 15 ans
j'ai été enlevé par des plutonien les
habitants de pluton et leur bonne santé
grâce minor vous avez les mêmes
intonations de voix d'hommes qui fait
rigoler quoi ben c'est normal c'est
parce que ses supérieurs
c'est à partir de quel âge vous avez
commencé à raconter des mensonges c'est
ça qui m'intéresse ok donc le mec post
ou le temps des questions quoi dre phil
collins le connais bien parce qu'en fait
on étale en colo ensemble et dès fois il
invite les huées à vegas et à l'eau mais
comme paraît que vous quoi tout le temps
de poser question qu'on lui fait de la
batterie derrière donc c'est plus sympa
quoi je veux leur dire du coup à partir
de quel âge vous avez commencé à
raconter des mensonges tu peux pas
répondre à cette question je crois que
les vieilles nous observe
oui ça stmicro non ça c'est monter ton
c'est bien sûr un micro en forme le
téton fort [ __ ] est-ce que vous pouvez
juste répondre à la question s'il vous
plaît à partir de quel âge vous avez
commencé à raconter des mensonges savez
je prends difficile pour nous de zonage
c'est qui nous bat les vampires [ __ ]
je savais que ça vous dit la vérité à
l'intrus ouais c'est sûr une et le 3
mars 80 à nice et n'ai jamais connu et
par an merci du coup j'ai été élevé par
deux tortues des galapagos minguell et
jean-marc problème c'est qu'ils sont
morlanne d'ailleurs avec 100 avions
tandis guen n'a jamais été super bon
pilote
vous allez me faire pleurer en fait moi
ok plaisante je connais les vrais
parents mais connaissait d'ailleurs brad
pitt et mireille dumas
ils ont jamais été ensemble le pas ce
que dit le magazine oiseaux ce magazine
n'existe pas que vous les humains mais
chez nous les cybers jeune homme c'est
bon ça j'en ai marre parce que là dans
cinq minutes tu vas me dire que tu sais
volet où j'en sais rien vers l'infini et
l'au delà
bon respect de prochaine nous recevrons
l'homme le plus en avance du monde soyez
là [ __ ] je les dis c'est la semaine
prochaine que des gaves l'aplomb madame
ne suis pas un corbeau arrête et du
regard las vegas oui et là c'est la
maison sur les collines il faut que tu
me l'avais fils ou fille du tambour
je suis relâché et j'ai pas de lâcher en
pleine ville du wisconsin d'un pote les
ps